[Music]
this
is crazy wow this it's happening
[Laughter]
i am joined now by dancing with the
stars pro
whitney her husband carson and their new
little one whitney
carson you guys are pregnant how
unbelievable is this news for you too
your first baby
it's absolutely insane i i think it came
especially as a as a shock because we
were not
expecting it so we both you know kind of
looked at each other and we were
very surprised so it's kind of taken
some time to kind of digest this news
but ultimately we are just like so
excited and it's just
it's kind of crazy to kind of be growing
a human
inside like it is bizarre i don't even
think it's hit him yet
at all kind of out of sight out of mind
for me it hasn't quite hit me yet
yeah he's kind of like until i see a
pregnant belly
i don't really know what's happening
yeah she's still so little
we saw a little bump on instagram
i know i couldn't believe it i was
shocked actually i'm like now it's
starting to grow a little bit more it's
becoming more real okay but i'm shocked
that you're shocked i have to admit
because
i feel i've asked you about babies
before and then
lindsay's pregnant so i'll be honest i
kind of thought you guys planned this
together and everybody thought that we
did what was so funny because
we really didn't we so when lindsay
actually told me she was pregnant she
told me about when she was like 11 or 12
weeks
and i was already pregnant i just didn't
know
so it was crazy which was so crazy
so i actually found out that i was
pregnant the week after she told me
and so it just was it was a big shock i
mean obviously
we've talked before and obviously i'm
super baby hungry but now that it's kind
of happening i'm like
whoa we need to slow down a little bit
oh my gosh and well you guys i i was
maybe also a little shocked because
one thing we keep joking about is
there's probably going to be some babies
that come out of this quarantine thing
but you you were not planning for one
this was just a pleasant surprise
no we weren't actually we were planning
actually august last year during the
show
so when that didn't happen we kind of
didn't try after that because you know i
the timing just wasn't right
and then all of a sudden in april i
guess
it happened for us which is just
shocking i am
still just so shocked but it just goes
to show you how everything happens for a
reason
so we're just gonna go with it well you
know i also gotta ask
how you even got the news carson did you
find out
after her did you guys figure it out
together what happened
yeah i was actually shocked she found
out
and then told me and i thought she was
joking
yeah so he was kind of laughing for a
little bit and i'm like i was like no
way
this is serious and i showed them the
pregnancy test we were actually in
arizona
and it just came as a i mean my hair is
a disaster
like everything that i thought i would
look like and
tell carson it did not happen the video
we took
wasn't uh wasn't the best it was not
rolled out of bed and rolled out of bed
did not expect it i had just a pregnancy
test in my purse just because i had it
and i just was a few days late so i was
like well we might as well but i don't
think i am obviously
and so we did it and i showed him and it
just is a disaster but
i guess that's how it goes everybody's
like you'll be pregnant once you
when you don't plan it and i'm like yeah
sure i need to i actually need to plan
it
and then it happened when we didn't plan
it so you uh you won't be returning in
the fall
um i have to ask you uh lindsay told me
that sasha is already petitioning
for whatever gender their baby is for
the baby to name sasha and i'm wondering
if you have gotten similar phone calls
from sasha or any of the other pros
sasha's definitely adamant that
we definitely name our child sasha
whether it's a boy or a girl he
definitely wants involved
involved okay i know you and lindsay
share a lot but you can't have the same
baby name
oh my gosh no that would be so weird
i was talking to alfonso the other day
because we announced that we were
private to him
and luckily they were randomly in utah
so we met them in salt lake and we
we told them there but he was like can
you do anything without your blonde twin
onesie and i'm like
i guess not i guess we can't
well lindsay i think is having a girl
right when will you two find out
so we actually already know
um but why you haven't
but we are waiting to reveal that a
little bit later
okay well is
what was your reaction when you got the
news
let's just say um like
like how we found out we were pregnant
complete shock like we thought it was
thought the opposite
we both thought 100 the opposite 100
what made you think so hard one way
i don't know and i i thought i was like
oh i'll have mother's intuition like
i'll have that
don't have it don't have it at all so
that's great um
i think we just i don't know
i'll have to tell you when the gender's
out because it'll make more sense and
i'll explain it but
it's hard right now when we haven't
revealed it yet would your baby be the
the perfect ballroom partner for
lindsay's baby
it depends
well i'm sure no matter what this is
gonna be a perfect little one
um do you see this baby taking dancing
lessons one day have you thought about
uh whenever you would have a child if
you'd want them to follow in your
literal footsteps
we definitely thought about it and i
think that would be weird if
we didn't you know i think it's just
such a huge part of our lives we
definitely
want to see if our our child would want
to do something like that but obviously
it's his or her choice so we'll see
yeah good job seeing his or her there i
was like
what will it be like for both of you for
you to not be in the ballroom this fall
because
it's been such a part of both of your
lives like i know you you know you
figure out how to miss
each other and how to make long distance
work and how to see each other so how
much will this change things
at home it'll change it drastically i
mean it's been a part of our lives ever
since i graduated high school so when i
was 18 that's all i know
um and i've done it every single year
since i've done every tour pretty much
and you know he's obviously been a part
of it for five almost five years now
since we've been married so
i think it'll be a really drastic change
i'm gonna have some serious fomo i told
i told dina cats yesterday i was like i
don't know how i'm gonna do it without
dancing i'm gonna have some serious bobo
i think it'll be nice just to be home
though and just prep for the baby
and get to watch it from an audience
standpoint i'm really excited about
tyra that's amazing news that's
incredible and i think
she's gonna be amazing but um it
definitely will be very different he'll
have
he'll be happy because he won't have to
fly back and forth all the time
there you go we'll both be like this
together
i mean it is kind of a crazy season with
this huge
change up on the host for you to not be
part of um i love hearing that you're
excited about tyra
what was your just initial reaction to
that news though because i think the
fans were
shocked that tom and erin would be
leaving yeah i mean i've known the show
just as tom like tom has really just
i've
coordinated the dancing with the star
show with tom so for him not to be there
definitely is a huge change but i think
change is good sometimes and i think
that tyra is going to be
great obviously we've seen her on
america's next top model so
we'll see if it can kind of flow but i
think it will i think she'll be great
there's an old saying that the show must
go on
now as a long-time member of the show
did you speak to tom
after that news came out yeah i mean i
just i shoot him a text and i just
you know gave him my love and let him
know that he'll be missed and
obviously you know tom and i we're
really close i mean
we always talk every time after we
perform on stage and he's always there
to kind of
give us some good advice so he's like a
he's like a brother
or like an uncle to me so you know
obviously we're sad to see him go
but he he was really in good spirits so
well and carson i guess i'll ask you as
somebody who's been watching for years
what did you think of it
i was shocked i was really shocked i
don't think anybody saw that coming
nobody saw that coming i mean when they
said
there were because dina kind of like
prefaced us like you know there's going
to be a new host just so you guys know
so we were kind of anticipating it but i
think when we heard tyra banks
we both looked at each other and we're
like wow okay
i like this okay
so you as the pros you knew you had a
little bit of a heads up that there was
some change coming
yeah we we had a little bit of a heads
up they just they're really respectful
of us
because you know we've obviously been on
the show for a really long time so they
were making sure that we were all okay
and just being like hey there's gonna be
a new host just yeah
just so you guys know so that i thought
that was really cool now that you'll be
watching
any celebrities you would like to just
watch compete any dream castings from
either of you
oh gosh i've always had just
like i would love to see zac efron on
there because he can dance and he would
be really
fun to watch i mean anybody who has good
dancing skills
like um i think um what's her name sorry
i forgot
bachelor girl pregnancy brain what's her
name
katie bristo's already on i'm sorry
caitlyn yeah
caitlyn i'm really excited for caitlyn
to go on because
i first did have some dancing background
and i guess she was supposed to be on
before too like they were in talks
before
and so now that's finally happening for
him really just i'm so excited to see
her do it because i think she'll be
so great wait was that the first
instance of pregnancy brain can we mark
that down in the baby book mom had
pregnancy brain today
there's been quite a few instances okay
literally like
are you okay i'm like is this baby's
first interview
is this baby's first interview
[Music]
this is this is crazy wow
this it's happening say what the gender
is right now
what yes what is it
later i will tell you like probably
gotta wait
yeah that is
[Music]
so whitney you won't be at home but
given everything we know about the
pandemic
and dancing with the stars how could you
see the logistics of the show changing
oh i mean just like in our world right
now i mean everybody's wearing masks you
know you obviously can't be in a
huge group a lot of people i can see the
show evolving into maybe
no audience which is so
sad because that's where we just we get
our energy from
but unfortunately if the rules still
apply to in california i don't
i don't know if they'll be able to do
that so i do see that kind of changing a
bit
obviously group numbers are going to be
a little bit harder because we're all
together unless everybody's quarantined
then it'll be okay
um the main thing i can just see
happening personally
is maybe the audience but i haven't
heard that's just my opinion
it's happening just like this baby um
when you were facetiming everybody did
you get any uh
advice from i mean peta is a mom and
then some of the other ladies
yeah no peta was really great too she's
so excited for us
she's like just enjoy every moment
because
you know obviously like sorry my dog is
oh it's okay
for babies yes so peta was just really
great and she was kind of giving us some
just positive
encouragement and just saying you know
enjoy every single moment
and even if you're sick just be so
grateful for this baby is the best time
in your life
you know just giving us really positive
stuff so
wow that's be grateful when you're sick
wow
peta like okay i'm trying i'm trying so
hard
so i'm just gonna try to get a little
more out of you has anyone told you
their partners
no and honestly every year it's the same
we don't really know our partners until
you kind of meet them or even the
weekend before
so if they aren't going to rehearsals
until end of august i probably won't
hear anything until the weekend before
wow and the gender and the gender of
your baby
is
[Laughter]
inside what do you think what do you
think it is do you have any intuition at
all or not
i think it's a
girl you think it's a girl okay
yes wow you guys just had really good
poker faces i was watching your
responses on the zoom and i couldn't
i couldn't read your faces at all